en fait moi je le
connais mal le générique
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour un nouvel épisode de la minute nécessaire
ou nous allons tenter de
répondre à une question cruciale et
essentielle et qui fait débat dans le
monde de la science depuis des décennies
y at il un lien entre indiana jones et
l'archéologie
autrement dit indiana jones est il un
archéologue
NON
mais on va développer un peu parce
que sinon il n'y aurait pas d'épisode
cette question est sans doute celle qui
m'a été le plus souvent posée car ce
film, ces films puisqu'il y en a quatre
ont fait naître chez certains la
vocation de devenir archéologue
alors c'est parti pour un décryptage
archéologique de ce chef-d'oeuvre du
septième art !
Tuons le mythe dès à présent
indiana jones n'a rien un archéologue
c'est au mieux un chasseur de trésors à
la mode 19e siècle.
ok mais pourquoi
qu'est ce qui ne fonctionne pas d'un
point de vue historique
alors évidemment on pourrait s'arrêter à
sa tenue vestimentaire et à ses
accessoires
il faudrait échanger son fouet contre
une truelle et ses chaussures de villes
contre des chaussures de sécurité
mais passons
ensuite son attitude, on note
quand même chez lui ou tendance à
détruire tout ce qui l'entoure en
particulier ce qui est précieux et
anciens et que je grimpe sur une statue
égyptienne et que je fait s'effondrer un
temple antique etc etc
en somme l'inverse du boulot
d'archéologue qui consiste à conserver
les vestiges à faire preuve de minutie
et de concentration ou le moindre
tesson poterie est scellé sous
plastique avec un numéro spécial puis
envoyé directement en laboratoire.
bon vous avez saisi l'idée je pense mais à
part ces soucis de mise en scène ces
films posent de réels problèmes aux
archéologues pour ou différentes raisons que je vais donc vous expliquer
d'abord le premier point dérangeant
c'est la vision qui est donnée de l'autre
l'étranger du sauvage.
un monde sauvage
on ne se trouve d'ailleurs les vestiges
archéologiques qui n'a pas d'espace-temps
on ne sait jamais où se passe l'action.
On est vaguement dans la jungle
et on n'a pas non plus l'idée de quand
datent précisément les objets antiques
et c'est un parti pris qui va à l'encontre
de l'archéologie.
ensuite la plupart des décors qu'on nous
présente ne sont pas réalistes
c'est à dire qu'il n'est même pas
possible techniquement qu'ils aient pu
exister
c'est le cas de cette salle couverte
d'une coupole
l'action est supposé se
dérouler dans un temple de l'egypte
antique
or la coupole n'existe pas à cette
époque et ne sera inventée que quelques
millénaires plus tard par les romains.
la première coupole connue provient de la
domus aurea à Rome
autrement dit le palais de l'empereur
néron construit en 65 après jésus-christ.
pour les objets c'est pareil cette
statue est par exemple est un mélange
d'inspirations mi maya mi égyptienne
difficile à dire.
ce qui est sûr c'est
que vous aurez beau visiter tous les
musées du monde
vous ne trouverez jamais rien de
ressemblant.
après tout toutes ces
incohérences c'est pas très grave
puisqu'il s'agit d'une fiction mais quel
est le rapport entre ce film d'action et
l'archéologie ? Au fond est-ce vraiment un
film sur l'archéologie ?
prenons le premier film de la série les
aventuriers de l'arche perdue qui date
de 1981 réalisé par spielberg et qui
détient à mon sens toutes les clés pour
répondre à ces questions et comprendre
la façon dont est traitée l'archéologie
en fiction résumons rapidement film on
né en 1936 et indiana jones
après un voyage en amérique du sud à la
recherche d'une statuette en or est
envoyé par les services secrets
américains
au caire où se déroulent des fouilles
dirigées par les nazis.
les nazis cherchent
l'arche d'alliance qui contiendrait les
tables de la loi.
Ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que ces objets sont des reliques
qui détiennent des pouvoirs
magiques !
Malgré toutes les critiques qu'on peut lui
faire ce film présente un intérêt
historique à propos des nazis justement
Je viens de vous le dire, une grande partie de l'intrigue
tourne autour des équipes d'archéologues
nazis envoyées au Caire.
et bien ça c'est
un fait très important dans l'histoire
du 20e siècle que nous explique ce
passage qui est selon moi le plus
intéressant du film.
Nous sommes aux états unis, indian est tout
juste rentré de son périple en amérique
du sud et donne des cours d'archéologie
à la fac.
Ces deux hommes, des services
secrets américains expliquent à indiana
jones
l'objet des recherches effectuées au
caire par les nazis retrouver l'arche
d'alliance sans avoir de réelles
explications sur les raisons qui
poussent les nazis
à sa découverte.
Indiana leur explique
tout l'enjeu idéologique qui se cache
ces fouilles et s'étonne que ces deux
agents n'est pas plus de souvenirs du
récit biblique et du rôle de l'arche
d'alliance.
D'où sa question rhétorique :
vous séchiez le catéchisme.
ce que dit ce
personnage est tout à fait vrai :
Hitler était réellement obsédé par les
objets antiques.
Les aigles et les croix gammées
sont des symboles hérités
de l'Antiquité.
A partir de 1930, les nazis
cherchent des validations de leur
idéologie dans les vestiges historiques
Hitler lancent des campagnes de fouille
un peu partout en Europe qui visent à
ramener en Allemagne des reliques : ce sont
des objets ayant appartenus à un saint et qui
sont sacrés
Le régime nazi veut
rattacher son idéologie raciale à des
origines glorieuses et recherche
obstinément des objets mythiques.
le problème c'est qu'en Allemagne niveau archéo, y a pas grand chose
à part des vestiges préhistoriques ou
protohistoriques, càd âge du bronze
et âge du fer.
En Italie là où les vestiges
romains sont les mieux conservés
mussolini a déjà procédé à cette
récupération pour son propre compte
il a fait fouiller la zone du forum
et à même tracer une grande avenue, la via des fori
imperiali qui relie sa résidence privée
dans le palazzo venezia au colisée.
C'est donc un sujet passionnant
celui de l'archéologie
nazie qu'a choisi de traiter Spielberg sujet
d'autant plus original qu'il est
rarement évoqué dans le cinéma : pour les
nazis on s'attache le plus souvent aux
camps de concentration ou au conflit.
Pour cela le film est juste et présente un
intérêt historique
je vous ai dit juste avant que je
considérais cet extrait comme le plus
important du film car en regardant
attentivement cette séquence une toute
autre lecture du film est possible.
Alors ce n'est que ma vision que je vous livre
ici et vos avis en commentaires sont
les bienvenus
mais selon moi indiana jones et les
aventuriers de l'arche perdue n'est pas
un film sur l'archéologie
ce n'est pas non plus un film sur un
archéologue féru de trésors,
C'est avant tout un film sur la bible et c'est même un
cours de catéchisme !
Pourquoi ?
parce qu'il a d'abord cette
phrase que dit indiana aux deux types des
services secrets "vous séchiez le catéchisme"
elle est lourde de sens de
cette phrase, elle est pas dite devant
n'importe qui :
deux représentants de
l'état par un prof de fac
la hiérarchie est complètement inversée
ici.
et puis regardez où l'on se trouve
comment est la pièce tout en longueur.
C'est pas une salle de classe classique comme
on peut en voir juste avant dans le film
c'est pas non plus un amphithéâtre les
fenêtres sont très hautes et arrondies
avec des vitraux
Et à l'arrière-plan il y a des rangées de
chaises
on se croirait dans une église !
pour rappel spielberg a grandi dans une
famille croyante et pratiquante la
religion est donc un prisme de lecture
du monde
Le discours religieux est d'ailleurs porté
par beaucoup de films
hollywoodiens est très présent aux états
unis de manière générale pas étonnant
donc qu'on retrouve des thèmes bibliques
sur le bien le mal et la fin des temps.
autre élément qui vient vraiment appuyer
cette idée c'est le tableau pendant
toute la séquence le plan est assez
large :
on voit le tableau dans sa totalité et l'ombre
d'indiana bien balayer les écritures
faite à la craie.
Cette ombre n'est pas
naturelle, on voit bien qu'ils ont ajouté
un projo spécialement pour cet effet et
vous allez voir que c'est une annonce de
ce qui va suivre
mais avant ça, revenons à ce qui est écrit
sur le tableau.
qu'est ce qu'on voit ?
des chiffres, des signes d'addition,
de multiplication, des fractions, des racines carrées
bref, des calculs qui
symbolisent l'écriture scientifique et
l'écriture scientifique c'est par
essence l'écriture de la vérité ou du moins
de la recherche.
Et bien qu'est ce qu'il en fait Indiana Jones
de cette écriture scientifique ?
il la masque, il retourne le tableau
et vient dessiner sur l'autre face son
interprétation religieuse des faits et
là vous avez le véritable but du film
qui vous ai dit et qui vous est même
dessiné et la séquence se termine par
ce plan
l'ouverture d'un livre avec la
présentation en gros plan d'un texte non
pas scientifique cette fois mais religieux
la bible !
Comme un générique de
début ce plan nous fait comprendre que
tout ce qui s'est passé avant n'a plus
cours et que c'est bien de religion dont
va parler le film, pas d'archéologie.
moralité indiana jones n'est pas un
archéologue mais plutôt un genre de
missionnaires fétichiste
j'ai vraiment compris le film